[Musique]
jamais dit que tu étais de sang royal
les femmes de notre famille sont toutes
dotées du fabuleux pouvoir de se changer
en grande Kraken
après toi tes sujets
je crois que je vais avoir la crise de
panique du siècle allez rubis tu as
juste à passer une journée totalement
ordinaire ça va aller
[Musique]
je me sens décalée je suis juste rubis
Gilman une ado normal mais c'est nul ça
tu as des pouvoirs que tu n'imagines
même pas
tu es la protectrice de toutes les
créatures de l'océan c'est à toi
d'arrêter ces sinistres sirènes mais les
gens aiment les sirènes
les gens sont stupides
[Musique]
voyons de quoi tu es capable mode
c'est le moment de voir plus grand
on se retrouve tout à l'heure pour que
tu m'aides avec les cours ok
je ferai tout pour toi beau gosse je
veux dire basse tu seras un boss tu
seras un basse en maths quoi
en fait tu préférais la toute première
version
[Musique]